This video is made possible by Nord
vpn start protecting your Internet
experience today with 77 percent of
a three year plan by using the code
biographics Nord Vpn Dot com
forward slash biographics.
North Korea is a country
shrouded in mystery.
They do not allow their citizens to
leave and they cannot receive information
from the outside world.
The very few people who are allowed inside
or under strict supervision from the
perspective of the United
States and the rest of the West.
We see Kim Jong Un as a communist leader
who is threatening nuclear war and
violating human rights,
and we also see them as someone who's
had a hand in a number of assassinations
of his enemies.
For some people,
that's all they need to know to form an
opinion and they imagine that he is an
evil dictator or on par
with that of Hitler.
But the truth about this man,
it's far more complicated.
Before we get into the
details of Kim Jong,
it's important to understand a little
bit of history about North Korea.
During World War Two,
Japan was occupying Korea and the country
fell into a state of extreme poverty.
They became independent again in 1945,
but the country was now a rock bottom.
It was extremely difficult to raise
the economy out of the depression,
especially since they were years
behind the western world in terms of
manufacturing and transportation.
This desperate time made some citizens
open to the ideas of communism where the
government is responsible
for providing food,
shelter,
and employment to its citizens.
The USSR,
it was eager to help,
so Russia provided weapons to North
Korea and it split off from the south.
In 1948,
the leader was a man called Kim.
Il Sung.
In the beginning,
things were actually going quite well.
Kim Molson kept his promises.
He improved agriculture and
no one was hungry anymore.
He brought industrialism to the
country which gave the citizens jobs.
They built up the capital
city of Pyongyang and the
country was progressing very
quickly.
For years.
North Korea was actually a head
of South Korea in progress.
People loved him.
Nelson,
in fact,
they loved him so much.
They called him the supreme leader and
began making up legends that he was a
guard with supernatural abilities,
but in 1950,
the Korean War began and the USSR and
China teamed up with North Korea and their
attempts to take over the south.
The United States fought on the side of
democracy and so they helped South Korea
win back their territory.
American soldiers are still stationed
at the border to this very day,
even though the war was nearly 70 years
ago in the North Korean version of
history,
America attacked first and they
were just defending themselves.
This trick of years of NZ,
American propaganda runs a ban on all
American made products and the feeling is
definitely mutual.
The United Nations creative
trade embargoes against
North Korea and refuse to
work with any communist nation.
After the collapse of the
USSR in 1991 North Korea,
it ran out of money and triggered a
widespread famine where citizens were,
once again,
starving people struggled to survive.
This was no longer the utopia that Kim
Il Sung had envisioned into son Kim Jong.
Il was doing very little to
fix anything during his reign.
If anything,
he exploited his power to the fullest
extent and did things that were truly
evil,
which only made North Korea as reputation.
Even worse,
Kim Jong Il had several children
with multiple mistresses,
at least three sons and two
daughters are known to the public.
Kim Dragoon was his third son,
born in 1983,
so it's almost was one of the few neutral
countries that were willing to work
with North Korean diplomats.
Therefore Kim Jong Il centers,
children to boarding school.
That boom was given the alias of pack on.
He got to experience a normal childhood
living in an apartment with a family who
worked at the Swiss embassy.
He was given lessons
on how to speak German,
but he had to enter a class of students
who were two years younger than him in
order to catch up on the reading level.
At first he struggled,
but he was eventually able to make
good friends with the other children.
His teachers say that he enjoyed playing
game boy and his favorite sport was
basketball.
He was an average students who enjoy gym
class far more than academic subjects.
He wore different in like tracksuits
every single day to school at home.
He loved watching the NBA
and American action movies.
His mother was one of
Kim Jong Il's mistresses,
an opera singer named Koh young here.
She would fly back and forth from North
Korea on a private jet in order to visit
him,
sometimes staying for
several weeks at a time.
It was able to visit several countries
in Europe and Japan and spent most of his
young life learning about the
world outside of North Korea.
When he was 17 years old,
he was taking high school classes
and preparing for graduation.
One day pack didn't come to class and
everyone assumes that he was out sick,
but days turned into weeks
and he never came back.
He was ordered to leave,
so suddenly that he never even
got to say goodbye to his friends.
He had begun taking college
classes in North Korea.
He was never allowed to tell anyone about
the secrets of the outside world since
the entire nation was still living like
it was frozen and some sort of time
capsule from the 19 sixties.
His older brother,
Kim Jong Nam,
was originally supposed to become
the new leader of North Korea.
The second son surely is described as
being very feminist and not appropriate
for a fierce leader.
Boone was third in line for successions,
so growing up he never really expected
to take on that responsibility.
However,
the eldest brother,
man,
he got himself into a lot of trouble
in 2001 now and was caught using fake
passports while trying to take his family
to Tokyo Disneyland and they got all
over the news.
His carelessness made members of the
North Korean elites lose trust in his
abilities for the next two years.
Now I'm would openly criticize the way
his father was running the country in
2003.
He was exiled from North Korea and 20
year old who was told that his older
brother was gone.
He would need to become
the next supreme leader.
When Kim Jong Il had his first
stroke and was 25 years old,
his advisors knew that it was time to
begin teaching him how to become the new
leader.
Ivr,
when his father died in 2011,
only had only had about a year of
political training at this point,
but it was too late.
At 26 years old,
he became the dictator of North Korea
once he was revealed to the nation as
their new supreme leader.
People are skeptical about his young age,
but they also loved him right away.
He was very friendly and mild manners,
and he reminded me a lot of people
have his beloved grandfather,
Kim Il Sung,
the superstitious Korean
people began to remove.
It was actually a reincarnation of his
grandfather who had come back from the
dead in order to bring North
Korea back to it's former glory.
There are very few living
people and outside of North
Korea who knew Kim Jong Un
well enough to be able to
testify for his character.
Kenji Fujimoto is a chef from Japan who
was hired by Kim [inaudible] to cook his
meals and they became good friends after
unwritten time for studying abroad.
What'd you motor was one of the very few
people who he could talk to you openly
about the outside wells.
He marveled at the fact
that foreign grocery stores
were always filled with food
in North Korea and were always empty
or knew that there was something deeply
wrong with this country and
he wanted to make it better.
He can find it in Fujimoto this,
when he became the new leader,
you plan to model North Korea's economy
after China whose wealth and boomed from
that production and worldwide distribution
in 2012 when he gave his first speech
is the new leader,
Kim Jong UN declared that this
would be a new North Korea,
and all the struggles were behind them.
When he came into power children,
they were still dying of malnutrition.
In this first mission was to make sure
that his people had enough to eat.
He spoke about his immense respect for
the loyalty of his people and how they
deserved so much better.
He says,
all people should never have
to tighten their belts again.
From day one.
Kim Jong UN has made an effort to
be the polar opposite of his father,
Kim Jong.
Il never made a single public speech.
During the course of his reign,
he kept US citizens out of the loop
and completely avoided interacting with
them.
His father and his friends in the
elite class enjoyed a life of luxury.
Any help from charities from the
outside world went to feeding the rich.
While baby's continued to die
of starvation every single day,
[inaudible] hats undo decades
of damage done by his father.
It would take time,
but he kept his word.
I'm going to set out new economic and
agricultural reforms that brought more
food to the people within a year or two.
People are healthy again and was a young,
possibly naive man with
big hopes and big dreams.
He truly did want to use his position
of power to fix this country,
but he would soon find out so this
even in the position of supreme leader,
some problems are far too complicated
for a single password to fix.
Before Kim Jong Un came to power,
generals were national heroes and they
were all a part of an elite class in
North Korea.
A lot of the power in government
was with these military leaders.
Many people don't realize that North
Koreans call their country the DPRK,
which stands the Democratic
People's Republic of Korea,
but the People's Republic was clearly
lacking the funding and power that it
needed.
One of Kim Jong Young's first executive
decisions was to remove all of the power
from the military and give some
of it back to the people and their
representatives.
His Uncle Jang song fake
was a decorated general,
so this executive order stripped away
much of his political power before Kim
Jong Il died.
There was some speculation that Jang Song
Faq would become the new leader of the
country since we're still so young.
For the first year of his reign,
Jenkinson Faq offered his nephew some
guidance in how to run the governments,
but it was clear that he was just
trying to be a puppet master.
This one lasted for about a year and 2013.
Kim Jong UN ordered the
execution of his uncle.
He was shot by a firing squad in the past,
whenever there was a sudden
death of a member of the elite.
Everyone knew that it was an execution,
but the government would explain it away
by saying it was a car accident or a
heart attack or something like that.
Kim Jong UN shock to the
public by saying that yes,
he was the one who had had his uncle
killed because his uncle was trying to
overthrow him and take the position
of supreme leader for himself in North
Korea.
If someone commits a serious crime
that are only really three options,
send them to a prison camp,
kill them or exiled them.
Considering how much power Jenksen Faq
had the North Korean military killing him
with.
Really the only option Kim Jong them
or say kills many of the men who were
helping his uncle plan the queue for
the other military leaders running the
government,
Kim Jong Un forced them into retirements
and replace them with people that he
knew he could trust.
It was later revealed in the international
press that his uncle was a pedophile
and he had an arrangement with Kim
Jong Il when he was still alive.
They targeted extremely young girls.
He would audition to be a
part of some artistic role.
I need to become his play things.
He had these young girls
bathe his naked body daily.
Basically why we're not
trying to promote murder,
killing Jameson Faq with a firing
squad was letting him off easy.
You can get to what inmates would have
done to him in the US prison system.
However,
the western media latched onto this
story saying he went on a killing spree.
This was also very shocking
for North Korean citizens do.
Yeah,
because they are a culture that
deeply respect their elders.
Well,
North Korea is still very
sheltered from the outside world.
Kim Jong UN has actually
made a lot of efforts.
You slowly incorporate
modern life into the DPRK.
He has invited in groups from around the
world to entertain and teach people in
things that that never seen before.
Like a group called SAF,
North Korea.
However,
these are special privileges that
are reserved for the elite class.
It has also allowed North
Koreans access to smartphones,
computers,
and hd televisions.
Students are also learning
computer programming in university.
However,
they cannot get access to the worldwide
web and there's only one TV channel and
that's used for state propaganda.
Also,
those phones can only make calls
locally and all of this is still only
affordable for people in the upper class.
Kim Jong UN began sending his country's
current and future leaders to schools in
Singapore,
Vietnam,
Canada runs Hong Kong in order to receive
a proper education and economics and
politics.
He hopes that they will return with a
better understanding on how to change the
North Korean governments
and help transition their
economy into a free market.
Many people get access to dvds and
flash drives smuggled in from China with
South Korean TV shows and movies.
It is now common for citizens who own
tvs and computers to see what the outside
world is truly like.
Even though I'm not allowed to leave.
Oh,
made an unlikely friendship with
a professional basketball player.
Dennis Rodman in,
uh,
2018 interview with CNN Rodman explained
that he wanted to give Kim Jong UN
present for his birthday by flying over
and American basketball teams in North
Korea.
No one in the country had
ever seen an NBA game before.
Despite the difficulty
getting into the country.
Rodman was able to pull it off,
Kim Jong and told him,
this is the first time someone
has ever kept their word to me.
He went on to explain that people usually
spout false promises about trying to
make peace with this country and that
makes it nearly impossible to trust any
outsiders.
For the people who have
defected into South Korea.
They say that the
transition comes as a shock.
There are so many more lights
causes people than they are used to.
Actress he owned me.
Park says that she is always studying
very hard to catch up to our peers by
learning how to read and write the Korean
language and catch up to everything
there is to know about the outside world.
We will never be able to read Kim Jong
Un's minds to see his long term goals.
If the truth of the outside world was
brought to these people who have been
living in isolated and depressed
life for so many years,
it would be a revolt and
Kim Jong widow loses power.
If he wants to open North Korea
up to the rest of the world,
it's not something that
can be done overnight.
Remember that these people are essentially
stuck in a time capsule at this
point.
Exposing them to the outside world all
at once would be incredibly overwhelming
and it may lead to bloodshed.
We don't know if he is more concerned
with keeping people oppressed to maintain
this power.
If he knows that the process
of globalization in North
Korea will take time,
what we can do is speculate
when he was alive and his father helped
himself to a higher and the actresses
and singers,
Lindsay arranged for his three sons to
have the ability to sleep with any woman
that they want it,
but according to Kenji Fujimoto,
the teenaged simply wasn't
interested in sleeping around.
He was very protective of his younger
sister and showed a lot of respect towards
women in general.
You fads to read books,
watch movies,
and play basketball over partying and
going on dates which you to was so shocked
by the boys' disinterest in the heart.
And he often wonders if
the boy was actually gay.
One day though and made comments that
confirms to Fujimoto that he did in fact
like girls just as much
as any other teenage boy.
He just wanted to fall in love.
Kim Jong Ung is married to
a woman named result Jew.
She was a singer in her younger years,
but often Mary and Kim Jong.
She began pursuing a college degree
in science and completed a phd.
The details about that relationship will
kept secrets and then marriage was only
announced in 2012 after he became
the new leader of North Korea.
However,
some say that they had already
been married for years before.
Then as first lady resells who enjoys
organizing events for how husbands and she
is often seen accompanying him in public.
While this seems totally
normal to the outside world,
Kim Jong Un is actually the first North
Korean leader who allowed his wife to be
seen in public.
He also brings along his sister arms
and one of his father's former consorts
with him to events because they are
part of this inner circle of advisors.
While may never know the
intimate details of his marriage,
that body language shows that they
are very loving with one another.
According to Dennis Rodman,
he met one of their daughters,
a little girl names Jua.
Many have speculated that
he has multiple children,
but they've never shown in the public
eye to protect their anonymity.
They are reportedly receiving a private
education abroad just like their father
did.
Instead of relying on a mail
outs take over his throne.
Kim Jong UN has been
paying for the training.
It was youngest sister Kim Jong so that
she can become the new supreme leader of
the country if anything
should happen to him.
She is usually present during very
important meetings with national leaders.
Bali is better than his father
and just about every way.
Kim Jong Un is far from
being the perfect leader.
North Korean citizens aren't still not
allowed to come and go from the country
as they pleased.
As a communist nation.
People are not allowed to
choose their own career.
They do.
You don't have freedom of speech or
religion and the press is a never ending
propaganda machine.
One of the main criticisms,
he receives this for the harsh
treatments of prisoners in the Gulags,
in the concentration camps,
prisoners are being used for uranium
mining and their bodies have been riddled
with radiation considering that he wants
to keep up with his nuclear arsenal.
Uranium mining has
become a necessary evil.
Then of course,
there's the facts that Kim Jong Un has
made multiple threats of nuclear war
against the United States.
This is an incredibly frightening thing
to think about and it has any Americans
on average.
However,
when you interviewed South Koreans,
not many people are worried despite the
fact that they live right next door,
but they believe that Kim
Jong Un's nuclear threats,
so the only thing that the country has
for leverage in order to prevent a more
powerful nation from invading.
Remember there are thousands of American
troops at the border and with all other
major powers in the world
owning nuclear weapons.
This is just a way for them to
become on level with mutually assured
destruction.
Meaning that no presidents in their
right mind would attack a country who has
nuclear weapons at their disposal because
it would mean both countries would be
obliterated evenly.
Military training is a requirements
for every citizen in North Korea.
Kim Jong never received any,
but the North Korean propaganda machine
has built up this myth that he was sent
away to receive some of the best
military training in the world,
so he runs military drills do keep
up this illusion he was given.
The equivalent ranking
is a three star general.
None of the young soldiers have ever
been to war and the military leaders from
the Korean world that will gone further.
North Korea has outdated weapons that
were given to them by the Soviet Union
decades ago,
and while they are dangerous and there
was no way they could ever win a war if
they took on South Korea.
A man named Robert Colin is
a CIA negotiated with North
Korea and he sums up the
grand show of nuclear power perfectly.
One thing every North Korean
leader has understood,
and Kim Jong Un does too,
is that if they lower their god,
they will be treated by the major
powers as the used furniture of history.
They will simply be discarded,
walkover ignored otherwise,
why pay any attention to them so they
have to make sure people care about them.
In 2018,
Kim Jong UN matched with the president
of South Korea Moon Jay and the
presidents of the United States,
Donald Trump,
in order to bring their countries to
a place of peace where progress can be
made,
we can only hope that there will be a
solution to this incredibly complicated
situation without ever going to war.
So Kim Jong UN and North Korea scary
stuff and you know what else is scary
hackers and not just off
the governmental variety.
I might sort of be joking.
It chances all your data isn't
really interesting to North Korea,
but hey,
every day we hear about in the news how
the some sort of latest hack or data
breach of some variety,
not good.
And governmental surveillance is
certainly something that goes on.
But good news,
you can protect yourself with a vpn
and that's where Nord vbn comes in.
I've been sitting in a cafe with some
open wifi network and I wanted to check
your internet banking world.
Don't even think about it without nor
to Vpn or let's say you were a foreign
person living in an oppressive
dictatorship with very
restricted internet and
you wanted to watch a funny youtube
video like this one very matter.
I know,
well,
Nord vpm will sort you out there too,
or maybe more likely,
you just want to watch gold local content
from your own country while abroad.
Well nor vpn can also do that.
Nor vpn is also super fast,
so watching video is a breeze,
no lag whatsoever.
So if you ever used vpns
and thought they were slow,
while that's certainly
not the case with Nord,
you can also use it on
all your devices very,
very easily.
Android,
chrome,
windows,
Linux,
and on six different
devices at the same time,
all with one account.
So that makes it incredibly
affordable also that are no logs kept.
Unlike some companies based in
the EU or the United States,
north vpn based in Panama,
they don't keep logs at all.
It's kind of like the
opposite of North Korea.
Great for your privacy.
Indeed,
they are the only vpn to get
a perfect score from pc mag,
nor vpn is offering.
My view is 77 percent of three year plans.
Just go to Nord vpn.com/biographics or
click the link in the description to sign
up and start protecting yourself today.
That's nor vpn.com/biographics
bio g r a p,
h ics,
and use the code biographics at
checkout to get started today.
So I really hope you enjoyed that video.
As always,
please do hit that thumbs up button and
don't forget to subscribe and I will see
you in the next one.